welcome to this video playing Tony [ __ ]
from Austria and this is one of the guys
I have one hundred percent against and
now their big chance beating me me being
in terrible shape why do I play the
Benoni actually hmm I wanted to focus on
openings that I actually know and I play
the Benoni not a good idea okay well
anyway this is at least a quite good
line in the baloney where black is not
experiencing any particular difficulties
let's see hmm do I play this one not
sure you will play a five anyway I guess
or should I ever come on maybe maybe I
can irritate him with the H porn yeah I
rotate him I irritated him a bit not
that it is a it's not the huge
accomplishment a 5mm do i play b5 I came
on let's do that try to at least play
play quickly some active play at least
on the bee farm okay
95 and this may be simply f4 but 94 this
is a bit tricky man a bit tricky but
also not not really a not really sound
maybe I can go to sea for though maybe
to see from interesting mmm ok is
completely ignoring all of it taking
here maybe I can now enter on d3 wow
it's really playing like instant moves
is it really so obvious all of it don't
know take care take be too ok let's take
that take that first if it takes with
this rook i'm going to take be 21 take
f2 right yeah this is they cannot really
take the six now I mean I don't think
you can give up f2 this looks very
dangerous to give up this essential porn
hmm I'm not sure actually what he should
do and I just took it okay okay probably
just took everyone here look everyone
Queen deform hmm I don't know I'd love
to keep Queens on really okay let's try
to do that keep the Queen's on the dark
squares are really weak and and this is
what I'm trying to to take use take use
of a chick with the pawn now come on
it's the most active move in the Benoni
just play the most active musleh
probably the right ones 97 I can go to
he go to be to let c 70 before using the
pen I have no idea what's going on
typical been only been only fight
I don't know
this movie 'it's feels wrong to me but i
don't i don't see a good reply may be
here I thought you okay too but maybe
it's not not really on okay I probably
need to do it anyway what now this was
as wacky stuff like 25 or this one I
g-form ma'am f7
and hey if it takes this is this really
a threat what probably is and what the
heck am i doing with my time yet since
unbelievable okay let's do that 30
seconds Sam come on she's not taking
Jack again yeah this is not exactly
great but i didn't i didn't find a move
really nah it's frustrating ready at the
moment time morning
yeah so this is the time of the year we
absolutely everybody can beat me and get
at least one point a scoreboard even if
he they lose all games at the moment
they don't check night at five come on
it doesn't find it okay yeah well I
understand itself it's a win anyway so
you can do whatever come on resign Joe
like resign I just I just I just cannot
play at the moment I don't know why I
don't know it feels like black should
just win here why does not coordinate
that the other computer says I'm winning
and I don't I don't see anything simply
and I after you five okay to this is
this is not working simply it's not it's
not it's not working from black account
just wants to go to evade I'm optimistic
because after sanad the spawn is strong
it is dark squares are really really
weak so this is better it just prevents
a five and the ideas to play 97 and get
stuff on the dark squares yeah black
wins here the valuation is climbing
climbing steadily up well okay it's not
possible for me to to see that I'm
winning with rookie bed but it's not
difficult e5 is the only only idea and
just relying on the fact that ok this is
active it's not not really good chance i
need to calculate IAM and well before
that maybe they even
battles we know this is this is really
ride down and hear ya at this should
player should play quicker here and try
something age 4 or whatever it's it's
not really working of course but try to
to muddy the waters a bit yeah okay
thanks for watching